I was working in New York City
as a photo editor
sitting at my computer all day
looking at stories coming in.
And I always dreamed of becoming
a foreign correspondent.
And I got the courage
to quit my job
and move to the Czech Republic,
where I got a job working
for a small business paper.
And in that time,
in that next year
the war in Kosovo was starting,
it was in my backyard.
And suddenly went from being a
relatively amateur photographer
working at a business
newspaper to
overnight becoming a
war photographer.
And as I dove into my career,
I did the classic thing,
I think a lot of
photographers do.
We want to make a difference,
we want to tell
powerful stories.
So, you know,
what do you do?
You go the most
dangerous, difficult,
toughest places on the planet,
and I did that.
And I was 26 when I started,
and I went to
conflict zones all
over the world,
because I wanted to
make a difference.
And I think we're automatically
taught to believe that
those powerful stories are
the ones that are driven
in angst and death
and suffering.
And I don't ever want to
minimize the importance
of telling those stories.
But I had set down this path
to become a war photographer
without meaning to.
I was sent to Gaza.
And this was when the second
Intifada was unfolding.
And it began as
kids throwing rocks
and quickly escalated
into people dying.
And there were plenty
of stories all around us,
but we were asked to
focus on the violence.
Obviously, that's what
sells in newspapers.
And this is a scene,
and literally there are
at least half a dozen
photographers next to me,
we were all photographing
exactly the same thing.
And this was a profound
moment in my life,
when I started asking
myself all these questions,
because one day I was
walking back to my hotel
and I heard this
music on the street.
So, I wandered in and
I found this hotel
and this couple getting married.
And this beautiful scene,
scene of love,
you know, in the middle
of all of this chaos
just captivated me,
and I thought,
"Wow! Why aren't we telling
these stories as well?"
Because they're
just as important,
they help us relate
to one another
and help me understand these
people as human beings
just like you and me.
And so, I think that, you know,
we've become attuned
to thinking that,
you know, the positive,
the good,
the beautiful stories are
just banal, they're boring.
You know, they don't really
deserve to be published.
What would happen if
we chose to illuminate
the things that unite
us as human beings,
rather than just the
things that divide us.